Hi!
I'm Ana.
Welcome to 'What to Say!'
Do you know what to say when you talk about your job?
Listen out for useful language for talking about your job.
Then, we'll practise saying the new phrases –
after this.
Life
is
hard.
Business
is harder.
I'm here
to help you
win.
Do you want to be the best?
Yeah.
I said,
DO YOU
WANT TO BE THE BEST?
Yes.
Good!
You –
what's your role in the company?
I'm the head of design.
I manage artists and graphic designers.
Good.
What about you?
I'm a content producer.
What does that mean?
It means I'm responsible for writing.
Nice.
And you –
what do you do?
Social media and marketing.
Do you like your job?
Yeah, I love it!
Good.
BUT NOT
GOOD
ENOUGH!
Now listen.
I'm here
to make you
the best.
And I've got
four hours to do it.
Stand up!
Let's all close our eyes,
breathe deeply
and think about these two important questions.
One:
What's the best part of your job?
And two:
Do you like the people you work with?
Keep those eyes closed ...
breathe deep ...
and think ...
Hello again!
I don't think Emir is enjoying the training very much.
So, did you notice the useful phrases used for talking about your job?
Listen to me and then repeat.
What's your role in the company?
I'm the head of design.
I manage artists and graphic designers.
What about you?
I'm a content producer.
I'm responsible for writing.
What do you do?
Do you like your job?
Yes, I love it!
What's the best part of your job?
Do you like the people you work with?
Try and use some of these phrases the next time you talk about your job in English.
Bye for now!